[Music]
you're constantly busy is shooting
shooting movies you were in New Orleans
right I dyed my hair for a movie pitch
perfect and that's that there's me I was
in New Orleans and I was actually
actually the last day that I was there
something really weird happened I was
driving from Baton Rouge to New Orleans
and I was listening to Adele's someone
like you and I was getting so into it
that I started crying and when you get
really into a song I just put my foot
down and I was speeding and I got pulled
over speeding and crying which looks a
little something like and it was really
embarrassing the cop pulled me over and
gave me a ticket anyway oh you find that
hard to believe
I was a weird to you I don't want to
swear it on something but I swear I
swear on Andy Richter's of life
I just like to be included yeah so I
would just think if I'm a policeman and
I walk up and I see you and you're
beautiful and you're crying did you
explain I was listening to Adele um No
thank God I
but I was crying and I you know I said I
used the movie card that I'm filming a
movie that didn't work he was just a
really big Butthead you're so squeamish
people come out here and say the foul us
things you go he was a Butthead waiting
for the lawsuit I was like that was a
bad thing I was saying like oh poor guy
he's now a butt-head on TV but no no no
one yeah he won't be identified we'll
find his we'll get his badge number uh
you know you did a great thing you you
last time you're on the show you taught
me glow sticking yes which I didn't know
and I get a lot of comments about that
people say they loved it when when when
Brittany showed you how to do glow
sticking right as obviously clearly was
someone who didn't know how to do it
that's so weird yeah it's really sad
that I do still do that not very often
and I actually have a bunch of dance
moves that I do I actually have a
signature dance move that all my friends
make me do whenever I get drunk or just
in the morning or whatever and really
wait a lot yeah
she's insecure yeah um but actually I
have a signature dancer than I wanted to
maybe incorporate your signature dance
move with my your dance moves this
stream oh the string thing yeah yeah I
wanted to show you my move if you showed
me yours mine's very simple there's a
string attached to each one of your hips
I don't know how you're doing it yeah
you just hit the string right here and
you do a little tug there and a little
tug there she's gonna add back to your
dance now yeah can we see your dance I'd
love to see your dance once again thank
gosh I have a boyfriend because I'll do
the whole dance it starts off with the
robot so goes like this there you go oh
oh
[Music]
who's a lot going on there I'm talking
for myself you're a robot
your arm broke and you got all sexy and
then you had to pull yourself out of a
burning building and then you'll thank
you who are a talk show idiot